hey guys it's Justine and today we're
gonna be checking out some of the new
iPhone 11 rumors I cannot wait I can't
believe that a new iPhone is just around
the corner welcome back to my office
slash lair slash dungeon a lot of you
had a bunch of questions about where I
am and what my new office looks like
soon I will be doing a video about that
but today we need to take a look at some
of the new iPhone 11 leaks eight to last
facts for sponsoring a portion of this
video I have been such a huge fan of
them for the past couple of years I
listen great is because I do get new
phones quite often through LastPass I
don't have to remember my passwords from
phone to phone everything syncs through
the cloud through the last pass app I
don't have to even come up with a crazy
different password for each one of my
accounts it has a really great Auto
password generator feature so if you
don't want to have to think of a crazy
password LastPass will also do that for
you the best part about it is LastPass
auto fills all of your credentials on
iphone on your computer on iOS and even
on Android thanks again to LastPass for
sponsoring a portion of this video and
being there for me over the past couple
of years when I first started using this
app and now it is time to get into the
rumors the first thing that I need to
look up is when was the iPhone
announcement event last year total
melzar on September 12 that's soon
September 12th the iPhone event
September 14th pre-orders September 21st
the iPhone was actually released and
this most recent image leaked found in
an iOS 13 screenshot looks like it will
prove our September 10th date for
announcement and 28 for actual phone
release of course nothing is officially
announced yet but this is looking pretty
accurate so keeping those dates in mind
that's probably around the same time
then will be having a new iPhone so make
sure you mark your calendars a day
before and a day after just in case cuz
we never really know what Apple's gonna
do I love looking at crazy concepts
because it just makes it so much more
fun just see what the future is gonna be
like because these concepts can easily
become real okay well maybe we gonna
that real because this this looks like a
like a freaking jelly bean this is what
the heck this really does look like a
jelly bean this looks like an iPhone
flattened
this just this is something but they
even have like a little icon from us oh
my goodness there's more look at this
you bet the volume on oh wow not sure
about the practicality mostly because I
need to have a case on my phone so how
am I gonna be able to use the edge of
this if I don't have a case on it which
the iPhone without a case is the more
the most beautiful things that you'll
ever see display makers have already
figured out flexible OLED screens have
they though have they
when will Apple announced the iPhone 11
in 2019 it's a question that I have it's
a question that I think that we sort of
tried to figure out this article has
Apple iPhone release and announcement
dates from 2012 to 2018 the last two
phones were on September 12 and the
release dates the 21 22nd so really who
knows they're saying September 10th and
orders would kick off a Friday the 13th
the interesting news a lot of the
articles that I've been reading and some
of the rumors are predicting that a lot
of the features that we thought we're
gonna be in the iPhone 11 they are kind
of pushing it to the 2020 version of the
iPhone so 5g 120 Hertz OLED Retina
Display 2020 it just continually keeps
being confirmed article after article
rumor after rumor that the 2019 phone
will be a lot like the 2018 phone
incremental upgrades faster camera chips
the next version of the operating system
which is iOS their team which I have
been playing with the beta and honestly
it's crazy because when you do upgrade
to the latest iOS it builds feel like
you have an entirely new phone some of
these most recent articles are saying if
they're gonna be calling the top of the
line iPhone an iPhone 11 Pro then we'll
have the iPhone 11 max and then the
iPhone 11 are honestly I wouldn't be too
surprised by this but it would entirely
sure that I believe it mostly because I
feel like they'll probably stick with
their normal naming conventions until
the 2020 release which is rumored to be
the most significant upgrade I'd love to
know what you guys think so leave me
some comments below most of the rumors
still seem pretty set on this three
camera design which I'm not sure if I'm
like the biggest fan of it because I
just feel like it's kind of like a
chunky block I think I would have liked
just basically taking the phone
have now I'm just extending and adding
another camera oh I love it this tweet
from mr. who's the boss if you like this
design or a retweet if you like this
design
I was thinking ever like the camera sort
of a vertical instead of horizontal I he
tweeted that in January it's crazy that
this leak has been around from that long
I will offer another LCD iPhone in 2019
the 11r I loved the 10r I think it's a
great phone a 13 processor will power
the iPhone 11 the a 12 Bionic chip was
the previous one in the 2018 phone it's
just so crazy to think that it's already
been almost a year already
Wow almost definite the 2019 phone won't
support 5g this is interesting because
what if Apple decides to come out with
another phone like another another
iPhone like the iPhone 11 5g sort of
like Samsung did with their five G model
that's honestly a very realistic
possibility I wouldn't put it past Apple
and I wouldn't put it past me to buy it
other assorted rumors a different phone
for China may sell a cheaper version of
their problems interesting and perhaps
one in India too so it's doing a cheaper
in screen fingerprint scanner for face
ID a new mute button USB see if Apple
decides to finally put us PC in their
new phones I'm gonna lose my mind like I
rigged something not out of being upset
put out of excitement because this is
something that I've wanted for the past
I think at least three years maybe you
know if anybody remembers the first
iteration of me saying that I wanted the
iPhone to have USB see leave me a
comment below a new way for users to
interface with future editions of iPhone
the touchless gesture control I'm really
into gesture control it's really hard to
get it to work properly all the time
every single time so will be interesting
to see how well that does work 20:29
phones we have a full-screen touch ID
2020 they'll stop using intel chips
ah also curious Mac Pro release date
when do we think that's gonna happen
Apple has favored October for a lot of
premium computer launches October would
be nice although my sister's baby is due
on October 14th
so Apple if your eyes can like maybe
just you adjust things accordingly so
that
could be there for the birth of my
sister's child but also be there for the
birth of my future child which is not
human and I'm so okay with that god I
can't wait like look how freaking
beautiful it is oh my heart well that
was just look at some of the rumors that
I've seen here recently I have done a
really good job of avoiding it but this
is interesting I saw this also the I
felt eleven are accidentally revealed in
the Samsung Note a 10-plus week I just
don't think that's it I feel like this
is fate
this is we've been seeing this same
design for months like the fact that mr.
who's the boss tweeted that in January
like like that's a little time to go so
it's gonna be a real shock if this isn't
what the phone looks like anyway I love
to hear from you guys what do you think
the iPhone xi could look like do you
think these leaks are accurate do you
think that they are going to wait until
2020 to release all of the goodies that
we thought that they were gonna release
this year either way you guys know that
I am one of the biggest Apple fans ever
so I cannot wait to get my hands on one
of them or two of them or all of them I
don't think I'll be doing an iPhone 11
our unboxing of all of the colors again
or will I I'm not sure that's it I will
see you guys in my next video don't
forget to subscribe so you'll know when
I post a new video be sure to hit the
bell so you actually get an alert when I
post a new video that's it for now I'll
see you guys later bye
[Music]